Well,
in general terms,
I'm in the business of really creating
intellectual capital or creating ideas,
um,
for uh,
looking at a different way at very
large,
messy,
complicated problems,
all of which have something to do with
competition and,
uh,
economic value and,
and,
uh,
really delivering value in terms of
organizations working.
So,
uh,
it,
it's,
I started out with a fairly focused,
although very complicated question,
which is,
you know,
what makes some industries prosper.
None others,
uh,
and then later what makes some companies
prosper and others,
um,
but ultimately that,
that core set of ideas and frameworks
and ways of thinking gave rise to work
in some very powerfully connected areas
like economic development and,
and most recently in healthcare
delivery.
Again,
healthcare delivery is,
is a large complex multidimensional
problem,
involves organizations delivering value
who are competing in,
in,
in some way against other entities.
And so that class of problems is,
are the ones that I've evolved my work
in,
into,
into looking at an.
And although I have a hopeless,
hopelessly broad bandwidth and the sense
of working a lot of different fields.
I work in the environment,
I work in social responsibility,
philanthropy.
It all emanates from that common set of
perspectives and ways of looking at an
organization's doing something to
deliver value.
Well,
you know,
I,
I suspect,
uh,
just just,
you know,
traveling around the world and talking
to people and meeting people that,
uh,
probably at this moment in history,
I probably that'd be best known for
this,
the notion of the five forces because
it's such a visible and,
and,
and sort of a sort of clear framework
that when,
when people encounter it,
uh,
all of a sudden it kind of totally
changes the way they look,
you know,
at,
at an industries and markets and,
and,
uh,
a lot of students get exposed to it
during their training and,
and therefore it still sticks with them.
I think probably the close second would
be the,
uh,
the value chain,
the notion of,
of,
of how we think about how an entity
actually creates value and think about
the cost of creating that value and in a
systematic way.
I mean,
again,
if my roots are in economics and,
and that's where my doctorate is in,
in economics,
there's a very simple conception of the
firm which is there's a production
function and there's labor capital
that's converted into output and,
and,
and that's fine for many economic
applications,
but in order to really understand,
thinking about strategy and competition
and value,
you need to go beyond that.
So I think probably that then would come
the,
the diamond theory for looking at
locations and clusters,
which is a close cousin.
So there,
there's been a succession of these,
of these frameworks.
Um,
and you know,
I'm not done.
I'm,
you know,
I,
I keep,
I keep pounding away at these kinds of
problems because what I find is that
today,
as we,
as we think about how ideas develop it,
certainly in the economic and managerial
domain,
there's,
there's a tendency to reduction reduced,
to simplify,
to,
to partition,
to specialize,
to look at the piece,
if you will.
Not the whole.
And of course,
rolling Christiansen,
my,
My,
my beloved mentor,
you know,
this was his sermon almost everyday in
class that it's the whole,
it's the parts are important,
it's the whole,
there's something unique about the whole
and how you think about the whole and
how you get the parts to fit together.
And that's the essence of what creates
true success in,
in most situations.
And so it's,
it's that struggle to understand the
whole and in these interrelated domains
that,
that really motivates me.
Well,
you know,
I,
this is a horrendous answer for it,
for a strategy professor,
but I'm working on everything.
Um,
and,
uh,
I would say that I continue to try to
advance,
you know,
all of my,
my major bodies of work.
But if,
if you wanted to identify what would be
the really the,
the,
the dominant intellectual agenda right
now,
it would be the continuing pursuit of
this kind of body of work on healthcare
delivery.
And most recently,
uh,
through some relationships with folks at
the medical school and elsewhere,
I've really gotten interested in
problems of global health delivery in,
in developing countries settings.
Uh,
which again,
initially looked like a totally
different problem than,
you know,
healthcare in the US,
but the more deeply I think in the more
you look at that at first principles
level,
uh,
you,
you see that the problems are very,
very similar.
So the hope is that we can create a
partnership which allows us to better
harness the massive amounts of resources
that are now going into fighting
diseases like aids and malaria and
resistant tb by,
by really revolutionizing our thinking
about how to deliver care,
see the,
the,
the thinking about healthcare in general
and global health in particular has been
dominated by the science perspective.
You know,
how can we come up with the better
malaria pill or a,
a,
a way of,
you know,
using drugs to treat TB.
And what we've come to understand is,
is that the,
that the gaining force is actually not
the science.
It's actually delivered and,
and,
and delivery is complicated.
You have to see it as a system.
You can't just look at the individual
parts of how you do one therapy.
Here are one therapy there.
You have to see the overall delivery
system and,
and,
and research in global health has not
really been able to take that
perspective,
just given the scientific roots of,
of,
of most,
of research.
I mean,
one of the very interesting issues in,
in,
in this may be a whole new subject we
could talk about for hours.
This is the nature of intellectual
endeavor and,
and,
um,
and even in business and even in
economics,
we keep trying to make every problem
into a physics problem where,
where you're down at the micro micro,
micro level and there's little particles
behaving on the basis of a few forces
that we can model mathematically and
then simulate.
And so what,
what we're,
what we have in most important things in
the world.
We have these complicated human systems
where there's lots of complexity and
multidimensionality and interdependence
and,
and we simply keep failing whenever we
don't capture that in our ways of
thinking in our frameworks.
And so that,
that's Kinda what I try to do,
uh,
with,
with varying success and,
and,
and constantly learning.
Okay?
Oh Gosh,
there,
there's,
there's so many interesting people
doing,
doing interesting work and,
and I,
I'm,
I'm very,
a collectic in the sense that I think
all kinds of work can actually
contribute to our knowledge of these
phenomena.
I mean,
you know,
in,
in the area of health,
uh,
I think actually the practitioners are
ahead of the theorists,
uh,
so,
you know,
people like,
uh,
you know,
Paul Farmer and partners in health I
think are the ones that are on the
frontier of new delivery models.
Really.
You don't see it in the academic
writing.
Um,
uh,
you know,
I'm,
I'm very taken with a lot of what's
happening here year around the Cambridge
community.
I mean the brode institute and the
ability to kind of,
uh,
kind of marry science and practice in
the human genome project.
I,
I get very excited about that.
Um,
in,
in the economic sphere.
I think the growing awareness that
people are not robots and,
and,
and their behavioral phenomenon that
guide,
you know,
how people make choices in the economy.
So the scholars that work on behavioral
finance and um,
and,
and it's kind of simulation of,
of how of how,
uh,
actors really make choices of which
there are a number,
uh,
here in Cambridge and elsewhere are
good.
So those are the kinds of things that
attract me,
um,
you know,
people that are,
are trying to bringing a,
kind of a fresh,
new perspective to a problem that was
sort of received and well understood.
I would say that,
um,
okay.
You know,
I believe that the,
the sort of frameworks and,
and ideas and ways of looking at these,
this series of problems,
um,
I think the most important contribution
is that those ways of thinking have,
um,
if substantially affected and
transformed thinking in those respective
fields.
Uh,
and,
and that's ultimately what I care about.
I,
I'm,
you know,
like most of us here at Hbs,
I,
I'm deeply,
deeply rooted in practice.
I,
what I really care about is not so much
the publication or the idea in its own
right,
but,
but actually the ability of a practice,
a practitioner to do better,
to,
to deliver better value,
the ability of a government official or,
or,
uh,
another stake holder to actually make
better choices in terms of developing
the economy of a particular region.
Um,
it,
it's really changing the way people
think and uh,
and,
and seeing that reflected in,
in actual practice.
And that's when I'm,
I feel like I've made my biggest
contribution and I feel,
I feel like,
you know,
that that contribution has,
has,
has been,
has been meaningful.
Um,
and,
and uh,
again,
that,
that cuts across a variety of different
fields.
But wherever,
wherever that happens,
that's,
that's the contribution.
I think I'm the proud of stuff.
I think as we look at questions like
strategy or,
or,
um,
economic development or,
you know,
read,
restructuring,
healthcare delivery or revitalizing
intercity economies,
you know,
through,
through different sets of policies.
I think,
you know,
and this may be a,
this is
always a dangerous thing to say,
but I think that we are much closer now
to understanding what it is that works.
Um,
so,
um,
now the,
the,
the real critical questions we often
face are given even even if we know what
works,
how do we actually mobilize a community
or a set of actors or policymakers
actually do that thing.
So again,
we see this an economic development all
the time.
Uh,
you know,
I can take,
take you to 10 countries and we can,
you know,
I could literally in 15 minutes we can
identify six or seven critical policy
priorities that will make an immense
difference in the wellbeing of the
citizens of that country.
And yet the stuff doesn't get done.
It doesn't get done for a variety of
reasons.
Partly it doesn't get done because
people don't have the right ideas.
Bad ideas are,
are a huge part of the problem in this
world,
but it also doesn't get done because we
don't understand exactly yet how change
processes work,
how to mobilize those change processes.
So it's really the thing that keeps me
up at night is,
is,
you know,
how can we get participants in these,
uh,
in these complex systems where there's
always multiple participants and they
have to sign of agree and work together
to come up with it with a good outcome.
How do we get them working together?
It's kind of worth it.
Chris Argyris and others who,
who work on sort of change processes and
constructive reasoning and how,
how people can actually learn and adapt
and change.
Those are the issues I think are,
are really the compelling issues now in
more and more aspects of society.
Um,
it,
it's,
it's not the what,
how do we get there?
Well,
I mean,
I think there has been a big divide
between those who think about those who
act.
I think certainly my,
my work and whatever success I've had is
partly because I had been able to break
that divide a little bit and be very,
very informed about the phenomenon at a
great level of tail.
Therefore,
the theory and frameworks that I develop
capture complexity rather than abstract
away the complexity.
Um,
I wish more academics would,
um,
would,
would do that would sort of live that
bridging themselves rather than see
their role as,
as solely solely the thinking part.
Um,
um,
and um,
you know,
I don't know how to create the right
incentives and values in the fields to
do that because,
uh,
you know,
right now the pressures are a little bit
the opposite.
Uh,
the,
the pressures are to specialize to focus
on refereed publications in the academy
and you get very little credit for,
for going into the field and,
and,
and engaging the practitioners and
understanding the phenomena firsthand
and therefore getting better insights
into how to apply ideas.
Um,
that's,
that's fairly rare and very hard to
sustain so far.
Now what you find is that the people who
can actually do that and we'll do that,
uh,
can often have huge impact,
but perversely,
I think the sort of the immediate
incentives that many,
many scholars feel or are really not to
make those investments.
So it's a real,
it's a real challenge on this
fragmentation of knowledge and ideas.
Um,
is,
again,
one of,
to me,
one of our compelling issues,
not just in academia but also in society
as a whole.
That's the market failure and uh,
you know,
how we,
how we think about solving that market
failure.
And uh,
now,
you know,
I,
I sense a glimmer of change in,
in some of the very young people that I
encounter now who are more problem
focused then literature focused or,
or,
or fields focused.
And if you,
if,
if you're really,
if your real passion is solving societal
problems,
uh,
or a puzzle,
um,
and you can stay grounded in that,
that helps you kind of work across
across boundaries.
But,
um,
and I think if have a new generation of,
of,
of young people who,
who really are passionate about the
problems that they see in the world and
can really have that be their highest
calling,
I think that would be very optimistic.
Step forward.